- My point was, but here
comes 2 million people,
which is about 98% of the market
when it's all said and done,
and they're going to have different rules.
(upbeat music)
- [Narrator] You got your perspective.
I just want to be happy.
Don't you want to be happy?
- We appreciate you coming on.
I know you're a busy man,
so we definitely appreciate it.
To be honest I did not expect you to reply
to that DM to be on here. (chuckles)
- You know, it's funny, Tyler,
I get a thousand, 2000,
3000 a day, a week,
you know, I get bombarded
and I just think it's important
I think it's super important to give back.
And what I mean by that is,
and I don't want this to
sound like I think I'm special
or I'm a douche,
but like I'm aware that my 30
minutes is really hard for me,
has a lot of value for me
and that by doing this show,
I feel like I, first of all, I
love this fucking card thing,
so it's fun. (Tyler laughs)
But two, I'm not naive.
I know that this is a big get
and will probably springboard
your podcast in a real way,
will lead to it being, have
more juice in the game.
And I think that's cool.
Like, I'm like flattered.
That blows me away from where I came from,
that I could do something
like be on someone's show
and it actually means something,
makes me happy and I'm happy to be here.
Thanks for inviting me.
- Oh, of course.
- We definitely appreciate
you coming on.
So I guess we'll dive right
into the first question.
Not going to be a total asshole to you.
I know I've been (laughs)
- He saves that for us.
- Yeah, exactly.
- You know what the good
news is bro, honestly?
- I don't, I don't struggle with much.
Like I don't, you know, it's funny.
I don't think any, I don't
think persistence is asshole,
I don't think people that
initially think I'm a Dick is asshole,
I really don't.
I'm deeply understanding
of the human psyche,
so a lot of things make sense to me.
So you can ask me a million questions.
I'm here for you.
Let's rock and roll, whatever you want.
- Okay.
- All right.
I guess let's dive right in.
So how do you feel
about people taking your
words to the extreme
when it comes to cards?
We call it the Gary V effect.
Like if you post a card
in Amelia, on eBay,
it jumps. It triples in price.
- I think about it in a couple of ways.
One, I worry about it
because I know that I'm
going to be the 800th,
most followed person
talking about sports cards in 24 months.
- Yeah.
- Right?
- So the first place that my brain goes
when you ask that question is
what's that going to look
like when it's Dwayne Wade
or when it's, you know 2 Chainz
or when it's, you know, Ryan Reynolds?
So like that is the first
thing that my mind goes into,
which is that.
Number two, I worry because
if you look at the history
of every single player I have mentioned
in any shape or form,
the track record of their
actual on field play
is extraordinarily high
outside of injury, right?
- Yeah.
- Darren Fox got banged up, but honestly,
I'm gonna have more conviction
about Darren Fox today than
I did even then, right?
So like, you know, like
when people are like,
first of all, when people talk
about me pumping and dumping,
I haven't sold a single card.
Very hard to be pumped and dumped
when you don't have the dump part.
- Makes sense.
- Number two, the people
that I talk about,
like it blows my mind that,
and I'm very aware of what I've posted
and I don't put, I mean I
want to post 13 times a day
about players and cards.
- Yeah.
- But I do it once every 13 weeks
because I'm aware of what's happening.
I, you know, I don't think it's a stretch
to be excited about Mookie
Betts or Devin Booker
or Luca Dončić or LeBron or Giannis.
Like, you know, it's not
like I'm talking about
like, I haven't said a word
about the following people.
Zion, high risk, in my
opinion, because of production.
- Thank you.
- But could turn out to be unbelievable
cause he's a fucking beast, but high risk.
Wasn't interesting for me to talk about,
you have not seen a single
word out of my mouth
about Jason Dominguez.
When people shit on me on Twitter,
I go look at their accounts.
They're shitting on me,
on like, talking about
Devin Booker or Luca.
- Thank you for poker.
- And they're fucking
talking about Jason Dominguez
and Wander Franco.
Do you know how much of
a trunk gamble that is?
- Yeah. It's a gamble.
- Yeah. Dominguez is 16 right now
and people are dropping
like a Bentley on him.
- Correct. So to me, I'm aware of it,
which is why I've evolved.
I wasn't aware of it at first,
then I became aware like,
Oh, by the way, Acuña and Juan Soto,
like I don't know, feeling
pretty fine with that.
- Yeah.
- You know like,
but once I started seeing
certain things happen post that,
I definitely got into a place of like,
and you've seen it, I blurred,
I'm trying different things.
I've blurred the card
because I want to talk about cards
because I love it, but
I don't want to do that.
I've...(sighs)
You know, it feels scarier to me.
You know, the number one
thing I'm settling in
is if I got to talk about a card,
I'm going to probably
talk about how much I own
at that moment,
because I've never
owned, I don't own a lot.
You know like, it's not like
I've never owned like
a trillion cards of it.
Like I've always been like pretty upfront
like win with me
or lose with me or what I really want,
which is don't listen to
me, listen to yourself.
- Yeah. And that's one
thing I like to preach
and I probably preach a lot of it
is people to think for themselves,
not listen to everybody that has money.
Just do what you do.
You don't need to listen to everybody.
- My objective here is to be remarkably,
historically, correct.
- Yeah.
- Like my objective is
to like, that's right.
Like I want people to see the
receipts of when I told people
to buy Luca at 35 bucks.
- Yeah.
- And Donas at 160, like that's real,
like everybody shit on me.
I'm being big on LeBron chrome,
but I was like, cards
are about to explode,
a lot of money is going to come in,
LeBron's LeBron,
there's 2000 PSA 10 Chrome base,
like this is just going to make sense.
And so when it went
from, you know, 900 bucks
or a thousand, to like three 4,000,
I was like this is bullshit, no chance.
Well, here we are where
it's like, you know,
today it's a 13-8, 14-2,
God forbid he wins this championship.
Or another one before he's done,
you know, I don't know.
My biggest struggle is
that a lot of the criticism
comes from places where
they're doing the same actions
against far higher risk thoughts.
- Yeah
- Yeah.
- While pumping Bol Bol.
Feels very hypocritical.
The only difference
between me and anybody else
is I have a bigger audience.
So I understand and respect that person
who was 1400 followers,
who's shitting on me,
but then pumps Bol Bol,
because when he or she pumps Bol Bol,
the market doesn't think
or debate it as much.
So I understand it,
but if you're gonna shit on me
for sharing who I think is good,
you might want to look that
I've stayed very narrow
across seven to 12 people from youth
and basically 80% vintage,
which is just pure supply
and demand in art form
and has been historically
correct now for 70 years.
You've done well with
Mantle and Honus Wagner.
You've lost on Mike Greenwell, right?
And Glenn Robinson, you know what I mean?
You know, like,
and so I feel good about what I'm doing.
Don't forget I did this before
a lot of people were born.
So I learned my lessons
on Todd Van Poppel,
and Brown (Tyler laughs)
and I've learned my lessons
of what everybody's doing
with Michael Porter jr.
And that's not to say Michael
Porter jr. is going to be good
or not. And that's not
saying that if he goes off,
like he's been doing in a bubble,
that you won't get that short term spike,
but somebody is going to be
left sitting with the bag.
- Oh yeah.
- And to me, if you hit Mickey
Mantle and Michael Jordan,
you're okay with sitting with the bag.
Cause it goes down 10,
20% when things are rough,
not 90%. And I feel very confident
in buying vintage basketball
with basketball's global popularity
that when it's not as
hot as it is right now,
in three weeks or three months
or three years or 13 years,
that I'm not going to be devastated
sitting with George
Gervin high-grade rookies
or Moses Malone or Dr. J
because they'll go down, but
they're not going to zero.
There's a lot of people,
Tyler Herro, Bol Bol,
Michael Porter jr., Devante Graham,
three or four of those
guys are going to zero.
- Yeah.
- And when I say zero, I mean three bucks
for the PSA 10 graded at
the bottom of the next cycle
eight years from now,
when they didn't end up being good
because they got hurt or they
just didn't end up being good
And cards' demand is super soft.
Added softness that it's been an a decade,
all of a sudden that's
a three, 10, $12 card.
- Yeah.
- When it's at the same
bottom of that demand
for Dr.J rookie, PSA eight,
it goes from 10K to maybe 7K, 6K.
It'll never be back at a
hundred bucks like it was,
this has been a shift.
Just like Mantle and Honus Wagner
and Gretzky rookies had a
shift in the mid eighties
to nineties when the last massive shift
in sports card collecting.
I think this will be the
biggest shift of them all.
I really do.
I think this will be a
bigger era than 86 to 93.
And I think that's because of 86 to 93,
because you have the
45, 50 year olds like me
that have money. So we're
going all in, in perpetuity.
I'm holding onto my Bill
Russell high-grade 57 Topps
until I die.
- Oh absolutely.
- Yeah. Most definitely.
- You have everyone in this
era learning from the nineties
and the junk wax era.
- They're not though, Nate.
Let me explain.
They are and they're not.
The modern everyone's so obsessed.
What happens when the cards get super hot
is you gamble, you dream, and you watch.
Let me say it one more time.
You gamble, buying high
end packs to pull the Zion.
- Yeah.
- More fun than being strategic
and buying Clyde Drexler,
86, 87 fleer PSA nine, right?
You dream all of a sudden you
know, Dominguez and Wander
and Nolan Gorman and you know,
Bol Bol are going to be
fucking, Stan Musial,
and fucking Will Chamberlain.
So you dream,
and then you watch.
It's a lot more fun to
do the first two things
cause we can watch them on
ESPN and CBS and Fox sports.
You can't watch Clyde Drexler.
- No.
- Yeah.
- So Nate, I believe that a
lot of people are going to lose
because I think they're going to go long
and what we haven't seen yet,
right now when you're in hyper hot,
it's like, you can't lose mode right now.
What's going to happen is
I think there's going to be a
lot of maturity and evolution
over the next 12 to 24 months.
What will happen is, look by the way,
even in our hyper hot,
I know a lot of guys
who lost a ton of money on
Baker Mayfield last year.
- Yep.
- Oh yeah. Me too.
- I was in collector.
Trust me. I know what you're
talking about. (chuckles)
- So we are in the hottest of hot of hot
and yet you can still lose on Baker.
Lamar Jackson breaks his leg in week one.
People are gonna lose
money on Lamar Jackson.
Of tied up money.
So I'm gonna go to zero,
but if you're in for
1300 and you expect 3000,
and now it's at 640,
and you don't want to sell
cause he's still young
and has upside.
Or you have to sell
because you need to liquid.
Cause I mean, 90%, 95% of the time
he doesn't have,
99% excluding me doesn't
have unlimited resources
to buy him forever.
- Yeah.
- So I don't know Nate,
the amount of prizm that is being printed,
you know how much Zion PSA 10s there'll be
when it's all said and done.
- I meant most of we are still seeing
the demand exceed the supply.
You can't find anything anywhere.
- Correct.
- I know they're ramping
it up to an extent.
- Bro, they ramped it.
Bro you know how much more Luca
there wasn't a year before
and how much more Zion there wasn't Luca?
- A shit ton.
- Because they know they're
putting money in there.
- That's right Jak.
But Nate your point is right.
And this is by the way,
this is why I ended up being right
about what I've been yelling
about for the last two years.
I have always been good at knowing demand.
Social media, e-commerce,
then within social
media, Snapchat, TikTok.
This is what I do.
It's just weird that it stumbled
on something I once loved
and knew cold for a decade.
I waited six months before
I start a fucking thing.
I'm like, I think sports
cards are about to get insane,
insane, insane, insane.
And then I laid there
for six months saying,
am I just trying to trick
myself cause I love this shit?
And like then am I going to look stupid?
To your point, Nate,
we're not even close yet to the
demand explosion being done,
but when it settles and
when half these rookies
I mean, right now every day
and by the way, I love it.
Cause all you fucking 13, 17,
23, 31 year olds, you're me.
So I love watching all the
kids doing their thing,
but guys, Colin Sexton is
probably not going to be
one of the 25 greatest
players of all time.
And you're going to kind of need him to be
if you're long Collin Sexton
at the price as he is right now.
And I brought up Collins Sexton.
So imagine how much shit
we're talking about.
- Yeah. Oh yeah.
- Yeah. (Tyler chuckles)
- I'm just happy you mentioned Bol Bol
because that was the funniest shit to me.
He scored 16 points in a scrimmage
and everyone loses their minds.
- Well it wasn't even what he
did in that full scrimmage.
It was a single highlight.
- Yeah. A single highlight.
- I got wow, it was a
really nice three pointer.
Better spend six grand
on an empty RPA. (laughs)
- Guys, the amount of money historically,
in the next 15 years that are
going to be lost on NT RPAs.
is going to be staggering.
- Yes.
- Oh yeah.
Absolutely. It's already getting there.
It's ridiculous.
- But it's really predicated on the kid
because if the kid turns
out to be a hall of famer,
you won't.
If Terence Davis becomes
a fucking hall of famer,
and the next Kawhi Leonard,
and his crazy $700 for an RPA right now,
Rob, a guy who plays a
little bit and shows clashes
in Toronto, becomes a steal.
The problem is that's going
to happen for two guys.
And every other RPA that's 400 to 50
is going to be a problem
because guess what?
As hyped as you are for
Luca, then came Zion.
And as hyped as you are for
Zion, here comes LaMelo.
And all of that attention
and heat gets amortized
and gets split up.
And now people are
coming in full throttle.
So people are cross-pollinating.
I've been obsessed with
vintage basketball.
Well guess what?
It's forced me to look at vintage football
because I'm like, wait a minute,
if vintage basketball has gone up 30 X,
and this is what Jerry West costs
and this is what Bart Starr costs.
And they were even, but
now Jerry West is 30,
you know, like four, seven, or 13 times.
Like what that's doing is
making me look over there
and that's happening to everybody.
Everyone's like, people
are crossing from Pokemon
to basketball and basketball to Pokemon
and soccer to basketball,
and basketball to soccer
and baseball to soccer.
And that all just stretches people,
which means all of a sudden,
the sixth best rookie in this MBA class
now collapses in value because
everyone's so also focused
on the second best soccer player,
the rare shadowless first edition Pokemon,
a baseball player, old soccer,
now we're gonna start looking at
I'm starting to look at comic
book cards from the fifties,
sixties, seventies,
eighties, and nineties.
I'm like, wait a minute,
here, come all the comic book guys.
Won't they maybe want to do cards?
Somebody look at these old marble sets,
Upper Deck just got the license.
Will that reboot Marvel?
should I be looking at old Batman 66?
Like, this is the shit that happens.
- Yeah.
- Pretty much.
Nate.
- So another one that we were wondering
do you see yourself as more of a collector
or an investor or like a mix of the two?
- Investor.
It's just the truth.
And I know that everybody,
there's people that feel that
you're not allowed to do that.
- Yeah.
- And you have to be a hobbyist.
And like, I don't want to lie.
Like in between 1993 and 2000, you know,
at 17, when I got, you know,
I collected, you know, I bought
a bunch of 93 Frank Thomas'
cause it was my card
and I have some Maynard stuff.
But the truth is that's
10 to 12% of my energy.
And 88, 90% is investor, you know?
And I, and you know, I think that's okay
because that's America's freedom, right?
Like it's supposed to be okay.
Nobody owns your perspective.
In the same way that I very much
am deeply empathetic with
people that are collectors only
who are struggling in this era
because everything got expensive.
That makes sense. That sucks.
- Yeah.
- Yeah. I use the investing part of cards
to pay for my collecting part of cards.
- I totally understand, I-
- So it's all self-sustaining.
- And that's awesome.
Am I using my investing
side of cards eventually
when I transact, how I transact
to donate money to Pencils of Promise.
Cause I want to make sure that
people in Africa have schools
or to be able to pay my employees more
so I can take less of a base salary.
Like everyone's allowed to do
whatever the fuck they want.
- Yeah.
I collect the Arizona Cardinals.
So I just sit back and lose money.
It's kind of traditional. (all laugh)
- I don't know about that bro.
If right now, I mean, I
think the Andre Hopkins,
Larry Fitzgerald,
rookies are under priced.
And I think Kyler Murray is a real guy.
- Yeah. I still don't
know how he got Hopkins.
I was huge on,
- Yeah.
- I love David Johnson.
I love him to death.
He's a great guy.
But once I saw he got DeAndre Hopkins,
I said, bye.
- That's cool. I think
Johnson's a running back
in a different part of
his career than Hopkins.
I mean, it's-
- Kenya has been playing
great when he came here too,
we don't need DeAndre honestly.
- Yeah, yeah. That's fair.
- So speaking of investing,
there's a bunch of,
especially on Instagram,
of these like investment pages
that will offer tips in
order for what money,
like pay them, and they'll
give you tips on investing.
What's your take on those types of pages?
- You know what?
I think it's very similar to
what happens in wall street.
The question becomes if
enough people pay them
and they all listen, does that in fact,
then drive the market.
While there's lower supply,
yes. Once this gets leveled out, no.
Look, I feel really, I
feel like I'd be very good
if that was my business.
I'm very good at sports.
I've done very well fantasy
and I've done very well at
sports cards when I was a kid
Kenny Lofton, Frank Thomas,
like I really did well.
So look, and I think that
helps people make money.
Like some people just go with emotion
and if you have an
analytical, strong mind.
So I think that like everything in life,
20% of those things
are probably fantastic.
And 80% of them are straight garbage.
- Okay.
- Yeah.
- That's a valid-
- Is that what you're saying?
- I will take that.
It's just the people who
like say you pay them to say,
"Hey, buy my cards."
What's the point of that?
- And that's the thing, right?
Like for example, I'll never do this,
but if I did that,
everybody would sign up
because everybody would be like
well, he has so much
leverage that it's like,
you know what I mean?
- Yeah.
- I assume and I don't
know any of the services.
Something weird about me is like,
I'm so focused on coming up with the ideas
that seize opportunities
that nobody else sees,
that I'm not spending as much time
figuring out who is the,
who's who of our industry.
I want to be friends with everybody in it.
- Yeah.
- But I spend 100% of my time
looking at population reports
against perceived demands,
against human psychology,
against Twitter
conversations and thoughts,
and this is like, I'm trying to learn.
- Yeah.
- It's a lot to take in.
Probably why I've been good so far
because I'm not worried about fucking
like fighting on Twitter
or trying to scam.
I'm like trying to do real work
and be like, wait a minute.
There's only 300 Hakeem Olajuwon,
PSA 10 #86 Fleer rookies
in the world. And if he's
a true top 15 player,
basketball is going to truly do this
and wait a minute, Africa
being the next continent
that is going to get
globalized the way Asia did,
this might be a good 25 year play.
Like that's what I'm doing.
- Yeah.
I think more people are focused
on listening to these accounts.
They're listening part
way into the process
rather than learn who to invest in,
learn how to invest, that's what-
- There's also. And by the way,
anybody who does anything
about anything who's
an active young player,
is complete gambling.
Derrick Rose was a hundred percent right.
This is why I think there's
a much more strategic thing
to be done with vintage
than there is with current.
If you can anticipate demand,
you have boxed in supply with pop numbers
and it's not in wax,
and you know what they
did in their career.
That's why I love the ABA players
because they're better than people realize
'cause they don't have their
NBA stats reflect their ABA,
but I also thought that
this was going to explode
and that 50 year olds
know who Moses Malone
and George Gervin are,
and they're going to want it
just like I wanted Frank
Thomas, you see where I'm going?
It all makes sense.
This is like common sense.
This isn't I'm right.
You should want a hundred
percent invest in Gary Trent jr.
You have no control over that.
You can be a hundred percent right
and Gary Trent jr. could end up becoming
the next Graham Hill and
get hurt all the time.
- Yup.
- For the next forty years.
And then using Graham Hill
may then still miraculously
have an incredible career.
Do you understand how
right you would have been
about Shaun Livingston
if this was the year of
Shaun Livingston coming out,
but what we didn't know that was
he was destined for so many injuries
that he could only be a shell
of what he would have been?
Do the kids understand, or the grownups,
what kind of player Shaun
Livingston would have been
if those incidents didn't happen?
- He was great.
- All time great.
- He was phenomenal.
- Scary different.
- Every investment is a gamble
when you look at it, no matter what it is.
- Fair enough.
But what I will tell you is
when the NBA has its 75th
anniversary next year,
and you know they did a 50th anniversary
you know, top 50 players of all time.
And you can kind of anticipate
that they're going to do top
75 players for this year.
And you know that Tim Duncan
is a top 10 player of all time
yet his card, cause the
hobby didn't like it,
or him, all I heard two years ago
the hobby doesn't like to dunk it,
the hobby doesn't like Peyton Manning,
the hobby only likes quarterbacks.
I'm like, that makes sense.
I respect that. The hobby is
the current state of demand.
My point was, but here
comes 2 million people
which is about 98% of the market
when it's all said and done
and they're going to have different rules.
I mean, I think the rookie,
the card that's considered the rookie
is going to be one of
the great things to watch
over the next decade.
- That I'm personally interested to see
as the influx comes in
Negro league players have
been under priced for years.
- Agreed.
- And I'm just waiting
for that to take off.
- I would like for me,
I agree with that karma.
I think baseball is
the most mature market.
- Oh absolutely.
- You know, baseball's mature
when we go to The National
or other sports card shows 50.
60,70 year old guys, you know
I'm sure the kids Raz on them
and they Raz on the kids,
they just look at vintage baseball.
That's why I think vintage basketball
was such an opportunity
because I thought the
next generation of me is,
cause I know all the
40 and 50, 60 year olds
that are balling,
and really call it 50 and on,
50 to 35, they're basketball.
- Yeah.
- And all of a sudden like,
do you understand that Ernie Banks,
I was just looking at this homework.
Ernie Banks' rookie
and Jerry West's rookie
have basically the same
amount of PSA eights I think.
Was I comparing, it might be seven.
Don't hold me in to this.
They basically have the same
amount, right? Of supply.
But Ernie Banks' rookie was two X
and Jeremy West is moving so fast
that this might be a little bit
cause it was a couple of weeks ago,
but it was two X.
And that's when I said, "Bingo."
I go, "Basketball is the culture."
This guy's the fucking logo.
This guy drafted fucking Kobe.
When there's a Jerry West documentary
of how his impact on the NBA,
maybe one of the greats of all time logo
and drafting Kobe puts you right there
besides what he'd been on the court.
How the fuck is Earnie Banks, no fucking,
I mean, listen, Cubs Nation's huge.
I love Ernie Banks, my best
friend Brandon's a Cubs fan.
I bought him an Ernie
Banks rookie, I think.
Or, and he made me send
it back and it's the best,
but nonetheless,
it's not going to be two X.
Jerry West is going to
be two X Ernie Banks.
So that's why I do like
the Negro league stuff,
but I also am obsessed
with civil rights leaders.
Haile, Jim Brown, Russell, Corinne,
because obviously our country's
becoming more thoughtful
about that. And that's
one that's one intention
not to mention those
are like for all time,
top 100 athletes.
So you know a lot of interesting stuff
to think about for sure.
- So how do you see, you
kind of answered this when,
after the first question.
What do you see this
hobby transforming into
over the next few years?
- You know, look, we just
had a major pandemic.
- Yeah.
- There's a lot of people out of a job.
The macroeconomic situation is vulnerable.
We have a very contentious election.
Nobody knows what the global economy
or the US economy is going to do.
And look, if we go into
a massive recession,
sports cards are not something you eat
or put over your head when it rains.
So you can anticipate some of that.
I think that's a vulnerability.
Taking that and putting it on a shelf,
if not for that, if we still
have stability in the macro,
in the micro of the
macro sports card world,
I think we're very early.
It's happening by the second.
I mean, it's an everyday thing
that there's a big headline.
or everybody who's listening right now.
And I'm sure for you three
every day, right now,
a friend in your life that isn't into this
is now starting to ask you about it
and want to get in instead
of making fun of you at it.
- Yup.
- Yeah.
- Yeah. Pretty much.
- Especially after the
LeBron and the Mike Trout.
- Yup.
- Those sales yeah. A card sells for what?
3.4 million people taking note.
- And honestly, the normal kid
is still not going to think
like they can find three, four.
I think it's Adam Lefkoe
putting cards on the TNT thing.
It's, you know, I got a lot
of kids following me a lot
you know, Steve Aoki
and there's just a million
things going on right now.
Pack breaking on YouTube.
And this is why I'm bullish longterm.
What nobody's talking about is the seven,
eight and nine year olds
that consume YouTube all day
that are watching pack breaking all day
like girls were watching makeup videos.
- Yeah.
- So there's a real big seven,
eight, nine year old crew
that's seven or eight years
away from really making noise.
So keep that in mind.
- Yeah. So a segment that we normally have
on our show is called baking biscuits
where we talk about,
we like to be crazy and everything,
instead of grind our gears,
we say what fucks our biscuits.
So is there anything in the sports world
that fucks your biscuits?
- That means pisses me off?
- Yeah.
- In the sports card world?
- Sports cards. Yes.
- You know what?
This doesn't fuck with
me, I'm empathetic to it,
but I think it's dangerous
because it leads to contention
instead of happiness.
Cause everyone should be
getting along and enjoying.
It's when people think their opinion
of what other people should do is right.
- Yeah.
- Yeah. As I said,
that same thing applies to
just the world in general.
- It sure does my friend,
but I think all of us in
the hobby world right now
recognize that the amount
of time that people say,
"Well, people should."
Or start a sentence with,
"Well, nobody should."
Or start with, "You shouldn't."
I just-
- You could say this instead,
like, I don't like when.
- Yeah.
- But, but that's really like, to me,
if you're in the business
of talking about,
I don't like when,
then you're wasting energy
on focusing on highlight two.
- Yeah.
- Okay.
- Like there's a million
things that I don't like.
I don't like,
I didn't say a single
thing of Project 2020.
- Yeah it's true.
- You know, I didn't,
I was asked a million times.
I didn't want to.
Listen. I don't want to shit on Topps,
cause I thought it was clever.
I love the artists.
I don't want to shit on that.
It wasn't for me.
It's not how I see things.
I think those are the things
that are going to go up
and down quickly.
It seems to me that that's
what's happened in that,
with that stuff.
Like, you know, I don't
like, I don't like people.
I mean people like, I think
every rookie is a vulnerability.
All of them.
I think Thomson Prism and Panini,
are making a lot of cards right now.
and Bowman is fucking complete gambling.
- Yes.
- Oh absolutely.
- The gamblers product
- And that's, by the way, that's awesome.
Because I think going to Atlantic city
and spending a hundred
thousand dollars of yours
and winning or losing
it is your prerogative.
I think there's a lot of entitlement
and people that think that, you know,
I've had some kids in their late twenties
have great convos with me of like,
you're not doing this
right. Fuck you to them.
Like, dude, like awesome.
And I love you. And I got love
and like, let's be friends,
but like straight up,
I was selling cards fucking
every single day in my life.
When you were fucking
sperm in your dad's dick.
(all laugh)
- You're not struggling right now.
You're doing all right.
- No I'm not struggling Jak,
I would never pull the um, no, no.
I'm talking about your
telling me that you're right
cause you were here before me
and I'm reminding you that
I was here before you.
- Okay.
- Got It?
This has nothing to do
with I've been successful
so fuck you.
This has been you came at me and said,
"You're doing this wrong. Fuck you.
You're fucking this up," as if
you're the gatekeeper of it.
When I was doing it for a
decade before you were born
or when you were born.
- Yeah that makes perfect sense.
- Yeah.
- By the way, I have no
interest in saying that
to any kid that's been doing
it for the last eight years.
As a matter of fact, I love
befriending all these kids
because I missed the decade of context.
And that's how I learned
over the last three years.
I'm like what happened with?
When the fuck did? When did Piggy come?
Why did? Why did? Why did the,
wait a minute, when I was,
every brand had every card.
Oh exclusive. What did Upper Deck do?
What the fuck is? What's trimming?
What's grading.
It started with for me.
Cause I left right
before grading a goal in.
Like so you know, like
I understand all of it.
I respect everyone.
I am not upset that I
get so much judgment,
heat, love, hate, because
I have a very big platform
and that comes with the territory.
I feel great about who I am.
I feel anybody that's actually met me
or transacted know what
I'm about as a human,
I've tried to do nothing wrong.
I've been unbelievably cautious
to make sure that I don't do
anything that upsets anybody
or does anything wrong.
I'm flattered when people
think I'm driving it.
I understand that it drives up,
but like the reality is
people love to play me.
Like what about Mookie Betts?
I'm rude. I'm like, what
about every other cartoon?
And again, it's one thing
if I'm sitting out here
and saying like, Hey Nolan Gorman,
who, by the way, I think
is a nice prospect.
A nice prospect. Who could
be a good baseball player.
It's not like I'm putting out videos
like Nolan Gorman is going
to be fucking Mike Trout
and as Bowman go through the fucking roof.
That's reckless.
I'm saying, you know, I'm
saying it about Mookie Betts
and Devin Booker and why did
I say about Mookie Betts?
Because I compared him and
his card to Trout and Harper
and Bellenger and then I'm
just looking at Comp's.
Again, all day long, fuck
Gary B this and that.
And then you go to their page.
You know, you gotta get on Dominguez.
(Tyler laughs)
- The Bol Bol hype.
It never ends.
It still got it.
- Michael Porter Jr.
- Michael Porter. Instagram
loves Michael Porter Jr.
That man is a walking injury report.
- Yeah. And by the way,
it's hard not to like him
when you watch him play
like he's played the last couple of days,
but people forget that
that's a moment in time.
And I remind people that
Derrick Rose looked like
a fucking top 15 player of all time.
There's still injuries Bo Jackson in 1990.
- Penny Hardaway.
- Like, you know there's
unlimited examples of this.
And by the way, I've got
other guys who dominated.
Well, Josh Rosen didn't
have, he had the hype in,
but he didn't have the
success in the field.
Let me give you other
success on the field,
but their cards are not worth a fortune.
Do you understand how hot
Stephon Marbury was at one point?
What's his rookie cards.
You know like, you understand,
you know, like how hot, like,
you know how great all time Ray Allen is?
- All time great.
- He's in the top 100
yet his rookie cards are
less than fucking Bol Bol.
- Yeah. (chuckles)
- Yup.
- I think people over-correct to the new
and under correct to the old
that's why I've been very consistent
because I don't want to look like a fool
and I'm old now. And I made
those mistakes as a kid,
vintage vintage, vintage,
and then look for
arbitrage within vintage.
Like, like I'll share
things I'm looking at.
Like, I keep looking at Tim Hardaway Sr.
You know, I'm like, man, he
was a really fun, good player.
He shouldn't be 25 to 50 cents
raw for his Fleer rookie.
(Tyler laughs)
Now I only think that
goes to five to 12 bucks,
but like you know,
but by the way, I'm so worried
that cards are so expensive.
I think a lot of people are going to have
to find those things.
- Yeah.
- You know, it's hard-
- That's why I collect what I collect.
I'm sure you've seen my page.
I collect hall of fame stuff.
I'm not throwing money into investments.
I just collect what I enjoy.
What I collected as a kid.
- Tyler, it's not meant as a Raz,
but I'm using this platform
to explain how I roll.
I haven't looked at your page.
I don't know anything.
I'm just spending all my
time doing real homework
on the macro, not the micro.
- Yeah.
- You'd be stunned how little I know
of every mover and shaker.
I know, I know a lot about
you now that I like you
and we're having a nice time here,
but I've no clue about who's a
collector. Who's an investor.
Who's a flipper. Who's not.
Who's vintage who's not.
Who's associated with who.
I know nothing.
I focus on my shit.
- Yeah.
There's so much to keep track of.
It's impossible to keep
track of everything-
- And I want to win.
So like I'm spending a lot of time
on looking at Mookie Betts.
Do I think he's going to get a contract?
You know, like, what do I
think is going to happen
in that Dodgers lineup? Short season?
How young is he?
What, you know, what's his war?
Like who is he as a human?
What's he going to do after baseball?
Like A.Rod, Shaq, D.Wade,
people that stay in the media,
a lot more interesting, potentially,
than let's say (fumbles)
You know what I mean?
Like you have to pay
attention to what happens next
if you're playing long, I'm here for long.
- Do I have enough time to ask
you one more question, Gary?
- Yeah.
Ironically, I try to make
a little extra buffer time
cause I wanted, I knew
I was going to have fun.
So let's keep routing.
I know you had another question.
I know you have other questions. Ask them.
- So what's the card you want the most?
Like what's your white whale?
The one you treasure the
most that you don't have?
- I would probably say the
highest grade George Mikan
in the world.
- Okay. I like that.
- I'll tell you why.
I think it's been very
clear of where I sit
on basketball cards and
vintage specifically.
And the 48 Bowman Mikan is kind of like
the Honus Wagner for basketball cards.
- Yeah.
- Actually you know what,
I'm going to change it
a little bit as well.
There's also a set a 1968
Topps Test basketball set
that is incredibly rare
that I'd love to have.
I have none.
And I'd love to have some.
I'm extremely hot on...
There's one set that's a modern
set that Kabooms inserts,
have my attention.
So I've been spending a lot of time lately
on what's the modern thing
that I can feel focused on
because as I've been talking, right,
what can I focus on?
And by the way, I'm going
to focus on players.
Now they're going to have to
show me at least the season
and I'm going to have to know
who they are off the field
and I'm gonna have to project
and I'm gonna have to pray
that they don't get hurt.
That's why you heard Acuña,
Soto, Booker from me.
Got it?
- Yeah.
- Luca. Right?
That's right. And by the way,
when I talked about Giannis,
that was the year before he blew out.
So like I was, I did a
good job with that one.
That's why it was a buck 60.
So like, so that's what I'm
going to always look for,
but then I've also been looking for like,
are there any inserts,
any brands, any offshoots?
Is there anything weird?
And the one that I'm kind
of starting to zero in on
is Kaboom. And I'll tell you why.
And you've heard it from me before.
I believe comic book
culture is coming to cards.
And I think that two things
will benefit from it.
Vintage comic book cards,
the old Batman and the 60's set,
the Marvel from 90, you
know, like comic book cards.
I mean (fumbles)
- Yeah.
- And I think this is early
and I'm surprised I'm even sharing it.
Cause usually I'll only share it
cause I don't want to be wrong
things that I'm like (thuds)
So I'm not, (thuds)
but the population numbers on Kabooms.
How hard they were to get,
how hard they are to grade,
the fact that they look like comics,
who they are,
the fact that there's now
golden green of 10 of one.
I always think like this.
If I went into a time machine in 20 years
in what was carrying an
uncomfortable amount of value,
would I be surprised
or would I not be surprised?
And the one that really sticks
with me right now is Kaboom.
I wonder what's you guys' thoughts
because I'm still kind of baking.
Any thoughts on that?
- I personally love the Kabooms
because I come from like a
nerdy comic book background.
That's why I love them.
I love the art style.
And like you said, how
hard they are to get,
the same thing with the
Prizm Color Blast cards.
- I think that's good for me to hear
because that's my hypothesis.
Comic book land is coming.
What are they gonna focus on?
Holy shit is Kaboom going to really,
really scratch their itch.
And look who it is, right?
It's fucking top rookies, top superstars,
start as basketball obviously is involved,
but like who's in it?
Is fucking epic and it's super comic shit.
And the first stuff, the 2013
stuff was straight drawings.
It's evolved a little bit.
Yeah. I'm hot on it.
And I've got probably
like 40, 50 right now,
mixed, raw and graded
is back to mean like I just realized
I went pretty far down this rabbit hole.
So let me be transparent of where I'm at.
- Fine. (fumbles) rabbit
hole all the time.
- Yeah. Go for it.
- You know what I mean is
if I'm going to do public shows now,
I want to be a little bit,
I don't know my exact number,
but it feels about 40 to 50,
which is not a lot, you know,
like in a scheme of like,
this whole pumping dumping drives me crazy
like that because I understand it
because I could literally do it every day,
but I just haven't done it.
So (chuckles), you know,
and so I think by sharing my numbers
of what I'm holding when
I talk about things,
it might help people in a sense.
People forget how much
business wealth I have
outside of this world.
- Yeah.
- Like the thought of like
amassing 5,000 Mookie Betts.
Let me say this number 5,000 Mookie Betts.
To then put out a post
and then flip them is the
great waste of my time.
You know, one guy really went at me
and I just finally said to him,
cause he like, he was not being nice.
And we were one-on-one.
I was like, "Bro, I get paid
$150,000 to give a speech."
Like for me to make $150,000
out of Devin Booker,
I would have had about this many
out of the,
like bought them all, flip them off.
Like, I don't think people realize
why would I ruin my reputation
for economics that are big for them,
but not big for me, that's not smart.
The same way that people
that are way bigger than me
wouldn't do things that I would do, right?
For say, right?
- Yeah.
- So I just wish people were
a little more thoughtful
and I wish people,
what's nice though is now
I've been in a little while
and a lot of people have dealt with me
and I think, I don't know
if you guys have heard,
maybe you can tell me or not tell me,
don't make enough to make me feel good,
but I think people are struggling
to get a sense of my kindness, humanity,
what kind of guy I am
that I'm actually in it.
- I would say personally,
I know when you first came in,
it's one of those things change.
A lot of people are scared of it.
I know all three of us were
a little wary at first.
- I was very skeptical in the beginning.
- Very skeptical.
- I appreciate the candor. Keep going
- And at last year's National,
I was helping work at a
friend of mine's booth
and you came up and you
were buying cards from him
and right then just how
you interacted with him,
I was sold right then.
Cause you were just genuine.
- Interesting. Thank you.
- And I will say this Gary.
I know I've been one of the biggest,
I guess, basher of yours,
but I appreciate how I
forget when he posted.
It was a few weeks ago
when he posted the cards
and he blowed it all out.
I do appreciate that.
Just because people are-
- We'll try and fix.
Look, I'll be honest with you.
It really stinks. Cause I'm excited.
Like who wants to blow
off their fucking cards?
- Yeah.
- But I'm trying, listen,
I love this community.
It was my life.
Like you said, every moment I breathe air
from 1985, 86 to 1993 was spent
thinking about the Beckett,
going to card shows,
setting up, like it was my life.
- Yeah.
So, I mean, I would have
so much fun at the Nat.
Like I literally cried that The National.
Like When I tell you I'm
going to lose my mind
at next year's Chicago
National and happiness.
- Yeah.
- Like it's going to be like a party.
- I'm excited. I can't wait for it.
- Cause that's the only
time- (Gary speaks)
- I actually don't even know.
Like, I'd love to hear it
actually since we're jamming.
What was the cynicism?
Was it? What did you think?
And this is now fun because
we're in a different place.
What did you think?
Like, I'm curious what
you think I wanted to do.
- My criticism wasn't
necessarily from you.
It was from the people who
took your word as gospel
and tried to push that on me.
- Exactly.
- Yes.
- I never had an issue with you per se,
it was the people who took your word
word for word was the best thing ever.
- By the way that's happening to me
in my real business life world.
A lot of people here only
part of the equation.
- Yes.
- And then they go and run with that
and then they get loud
and they annoy people.
- Yes. Thank you.
- That makes sense.
- If you hear a kid drop the F bomb,
you ask where they heard it from
and then you blame where
they heard it from.
Not necessarily the kid.
- Yeah. I totally, totally, totally.
It makes a ton of sense.
Tyler, what about you?
What was your thought?
- It is pretty much what
(clears throat) Jak said.
- It's more so-
- Is it one of these things
where there was a bunch of
you guys are in it,
now, all of a sudden comes this new breed.
The only thing they know
is what they're parodying
from my content,
or maybe one other place.
And they're trying to impose on you
when you've been putting
in the work for three,
four, six years. And you know
what you're quote unquote
talking about?
- Pretty much.
- Basically-
I've been in this hobby.
I'm 30 years old. I've
been doing this literally
since I was born, my dad's
collected for 50 years.
So I mean I think I genuinely have an idea
of what's going on.
And then all of a sudden
you got people telling you
like to do this, to do that.
And that's just not my thing.
- Is it obvious to you
that it was happening
for the six to 18 months
prior to me getting loud about it,
that the momentum started building?
How do you see that Tyler?
- It was a little bit,
you could tell that there
was an influx coming.
You just didn't know when
it was going to come.
And then the first video,
I can't remember what you
posted, what the first video was,
but then when I saw that first video,
my first reaction was, oh
shit, here we go. (laughs)
And sure enough, that's when
everybody started coming in
and everybody started cycling in
just baking money, spending
money, like it was nothing.
It was a sight to see, I'll give you that,
but it was something that
was pretty surprising.
- Well, let's remind everybody
for the sake of the conversation.
That was over two years ago.
- Yes.
- And that was a lot of money coming in
from your perspective,
based on the base of that time.
Those are micro numbers
compared to where we are.
- Oh yeah. Most definitely.
- A lot of people are like,
"Gary, you're going to make
people lose all this fluid."
I'm like I don't think you understand.
The people that listened
to me two years ago
have already made more than
everything they can lose
under inventory.
- Yeah, pretty much.
- I just found it crazy how the pandemic
made the card market boom the way it did.
I wouldn't have expected that.
Then you realize all they
have to do is buy cards.
- Jak, you'll love this.
Every time somebody's like,
"Gary you, you, you." I'm like,
let me tell you something.
This is why you can never win
when you have a big platform.
I was criticized March, April, May, in May
on social for not talking
about cards for three months.
Like you remember that,
you guys are in this,
- Yeah, I do. Trust me, I do.
- Oh fuck this see, see?
This is the proof-
- Yeah. He's out. He's out now
- He probably sold all his Acuña's.
I have every one of them in my safe.
Like dah, dah, dah, dah.
Meanwhile, what was happening was
the hobby exploded during that time.
I had a company to make sure
it didn't go out of business.
I started a nonprofit execution
called the Olin Challenge
and raised $61 million to feed the hungry.
I was doing noble things
yet getting shit on for not,
like do you know how sad it is
to be in a place where
you lose no matter what?
You talk and you're shit,
you don't talk and you're shit.
You talk and you're the
reason it's exploding.
In the same sentence, somebody goes,
"The hobby exploded during COVID."
I didn't say shit during the
first three months of COVID
cause I was trying to do the
things I just said I was doing.
So how the fuck do you win?
- Plus with the amount of
homework that you put in,
we're seeing new trends.
We're seeing a lot of the similar trends
that you were predicting before,
but we're seeing new trends come about.
So that time off could
have also been interpreted
as you doing homework as to new trends
and keep up with those.
- Yeah. I'm sharing the real truth here,
which is like, I was just
trying to do good for the world
and make sure my obligations were okay.
And to your point, Nate,
I wish I bought on the
things I believed in
during that time because
once I picked my head back up
in like June, July,
when I went to go buy vintage,
it already started moving.
And now, like the cat's out of the bag,
it's just too obvious.
By the way, if Gary
Vaynerchuk never existed,
all you youngsters that are
real like kind of operators
from an investing
standpoint, not collecting,
would have all gravitated
there eventually anyway
cause it's the actual answer to the test.
- Yeah.
- There's no problem with that.
- So Tyler's dad ended
and I don't know if he
was just pure collector,
but having 50 years experience.
Like, let me tell you this, the old men,
let's call it what it is,
that were talking to me in
the mall of Edison, New Jersey
in 1992 about Carla Ceský and Fred Lynn
and get them in nice shape,
you know, back then there
was no talk about centering.
It was corners and creases
and I'm like, fuck these guys,
it's all (familiar phrase) (laughs)
You know, these guys don't get it.
Things that my friends said
around me when I got back in.
They're like, "Gary, nobody gives a fuck
about Wilt Chamberlain.
They care about Zion."
And I'm like, okay.
Cause I already lived people
telling me to buy Pete Rose
and Roberto Clemente.
And instead, I decided to
buy 4,000 David Justice
rookie cards.
- Yeah. (laughs)
- So like, you know,
one of the things that was
fun for me at The National
was cause you know, again,
you saw I was there as a dealer
and a part of the community.
I didn't have some fancy
suit, like I was, I'm there.
I don't want the, like I turned down fancy
from all the companies there
cause I actually have,
I want to do the show.
- Yeah.
- What was really fun for me though,
is I could feel the hobby
get a different sense with me
because I spent hours and hours talking
and I don't think people really realize
how much I like lived cards.
Like if you want to talk
about like 1984 to 1994,
I know everything.
I know everything about
how LPG baseball came out.
It was hot for five
minutes and then wasn't.
I know everything about
fucking Brian Taylor
and Gregg Jefferies and fuck face this,
and Mark Grace rookies,
two guys on the same card.
I can go deep, deep, deep, deep, deep.
- Yeah.
- You know, you want to talk
about fucking Wally Joyner,
87 tops, I can tell you
what have you, you know.
- That's a name I haven't
heard in a while. (laughs)
- And I think that I'm a mature, smart,
successful operator at this point.
And that's why a lot of
the things I'm saying
I feel great about,
I understand people's cynicism.
I understand people's concerns.
This bubble will burst
because every market goes up and down.
And when it bursts, no
matter how I've said it,
no matter how, like this
was a great interview,
I appreciate it. Like, no
matter how clear I've been,
I'm prepared for many people to blame me.
I just know how it works.
There will be literally guys
who fucking made hundreds of thousands
to millions of dollars during the up.
And when they lose half of it,
even though they've made
more than they've ever made,
well, they'll turn and blame me
because they didn't heed
buying 86, 87 Fleer.
They didn't heed buying
61 Fleer basketball
and 57 Topps football and basketball.
They didn't heed what
it was actually saying
and they let their emotions and greed
and gambling and want of the short money
make them go to some 12 year old in Peru.
And that's why they're
going to get caught.
- Yeah.
- Yup.
Well we definitely appreciate
you coming on Gary.
Like I said, I know you're a busy man,
so it means a lot to us that you came on.
- Of course. Tyler and gang,
what questions were on the docket
that we didn't get to
look through rapid fire?
I can't do this often,
so I'd like to get as much out
to the universe as possible.
And I like you guys.
- You mind if I get mine
off, I have one last one.
- So we've seen like a bunch of people,
literally camping out at
the Walmarts, Targets,
they'll bring chairs,
they'll bring a book next to the-
- Can I save you time?
And I get blamed for that
a lot too. Flip life,
I've seen all the blame.
That's on Walmart.
- Okay. I respect that.
- Cabbage Patch Kids and
Power Rangers existed too.
All that Walmart and Target have to do
is put four per customer.
And of course, people will
bring their cousin and wife,
but it could be better.
- Yeah.
- That's the result like
I'm seeing a lot of people
really push for that limit per customer.
So I'm glad to see that you like that.
- It should. And by the way,
and I don't blame the
people that are going there
and not limit per customer
because they're living their life.
That's, you know, Apple, isn't like,
they're trying to feed their family.
And then this is what they, like,
is your want of collecting, you know,
Vlad Guerrero Jr. inserts that
are only available at Target,
more valuable than another
man or woman's Vlad
to pay the mortgage for their family.
And this is what they think
is the right thing to do.
- Yeah.
- It's hard.
This is back to who's right, you know?
Like Walmart, like don't blame me.
Don't blame somebody who's
trying to do something
for their family.
Blame a system. Blame...
Topps can do it on their website,
direct to consumer with limits.
So like, let's get real here.
Let's have a conversation.
Not fucking, just spill
venom at each other.
- Yeah.
- Also, how was signing for Topps?
Was that cool?
Like, was that a cool experience?
- I remember one of the people
that dislikes me the most
is like, "He's only here."
I got paid 25K on the record,
which again, is an
ungodly amount of money,
but like just not for me
at this point in my career,
it's not why I did it.
And I would have paid them
25K to have a fucking card.
Are you kidding me?
I was at the Topps series too.
Are you nuts?
(Tyler chuckles)
- All right.
That's all I got.
- What else? We got four more minutes.
What else? (fumbles)
- The last question I had for you was
what's your favorite hobby story?
- I'm obsessed when
people find like uncle Bob
or grandpa Johnny's like
collection in the app,
like I can't wait to garage sale.
Like you can't imagine Tyler.
I'm like COVID's killing
me because of The National.
And because the garage selling,
because I'm going to
garage sale like a mother
I'm going to buy like old books
like a thousand of them,
take them home and open them like packs
hoping somebody slid a fucking,
you know, Wilt Chamberlain
61 into their books. (laughs)
So I love those.
I love the hunt and I do love,
I do think the hobby is
going to evolve a little.
I think the hobby will follow me
not because everyone's going to follow me
because they think I'm right
or I'm going to make them money.
I think they're going to get
to the same observations that I have,
which is like, supplying the main matter.
So if something's very rare,
whether manifested by the card companies
or like everybody's accepted
Panini making 10 of these,
but yet they're letting things
that only have 10 population
and are rare sit undervalued.
- Yeah.
- Do your shit.
I for a long time talked about now,
it's finally moving and I'm pissed
cause I've been not paying
attention to them like in a month
if fucking skyrocketing,
but I know that I've
mentioned in the past,
so I'll bring it up.
I was obsessed with
the 1972 Icee Bear set.
- Oh my God.
It's funny you say that
because that's one of my dad's
favorite sets of all time.
He actually bought a bunch
of them not too long ago.
- I got into the hobby,
I'm doing my research.
I'm obsessed with vintage basketball.
It's expensive now.
It's fucking, I wish I bought all of it.
You know, but I'm like these stuffy too.
First of all, I love
nostalgia and marketing.
I'm a marketing guy.
So all the Sugar Daddy,
Jak In The Box, you know
Carvel discs from the set,
like all that shit fucks with me heavy.
I'm into all of it.
- Yeah. My dad-
- Everybody thinks it's junk.
I found a guy at The National,
I bought all his shit and he's like,
"Everyone thinks it's junk."
I'm like, I think it's
going to be more valuable
than the fucking real shit.
And I still do.
I think the 85 Nike Jordan
has a chance of being more valuable
than a fucking 86 Fleer Jordan
because I think shit changes
and supply and demand matters.
And news things are extremely rare
and they weren't manufactured rare
and then put into sleeves.
They're rare because
it wasn't manufactured.
And then it got deemed the fuck up.
- Yeah.
- So more art and antique
and I just fucking love that space.
So anyway, the thrill of
the hunt, Nate, two ways.
One, literally going to a garage sale
and buying binders of first
edition Shadowless Pokemon
for a great deal
or finding old magazines,
or finding, you know,
some of the hand cut shit.
I'm like learning.
I wish people knew how
deep I was in this game.
I'm studying every magazine that exists
that has hand cut rookies in them.
So I stumble on them at a
thrift store or a garage sale.
- Yeah.
- Like I know the editions
of like Sports Illustrated for Kids
or European stuff or something like
I'm doing the work,
which is like the complete reverse
of what a lot of people think I'm doing,
which is like something.
I'm going harder than the
people that are making fun of me
that they go hard.
- No. And I definitely appreciate that.
I appreciate anyone who puts the effort.
- Yeah, exactly.
- Thanks Tyler.
And so, I guess, with
the finish thought is
the two things I love the
most is physically hunting,
garage sales, thrift stores,
and virtually hunting.
Living in SGC Beckett and PSA Pop reports
and then looking for weird stuff
that I think say to myself.
Okay. So wait a minute.
So if I'm right about vintage basketball
which now has been proven to be true,
this was me two years ago.
Well then there's a trickle
down effect if 57 Russell
and 61 Oscar, and 69 Jabbar Alcindor
go up 10 X like I think it will,
what are the other collateral things
that will move because of that?
And that's what stumbled me an Icee Bear,
like these are fucking dope.
- Yeah they're awesome.
- They're awesome, they're awesome set.
And I think it's going
to go through the roof
because I also think a
lot of advertising people
and antiquers, like cards
are going to get big big.
It's not just Sneaker Kids.
It's going to be lawyers.
It's going to be ad executives.
And the advertising
executives from my world,
they're going to think an
Icee Bear or Sugar Daddy
or Carvel or Gatorade Collaboration
Card is actually cooler
than the accepted hobby
Topps of Fleer rookie.
- Yeah.
- Oh, that's what I think.
Actually I loved the obscure shit
that you can't find like a,
there's a set it was
made in the late sixties.
I forget the name of it.
It was made in Wisconsin
by a hotdog company.
And I can't remember the
name. Starts with an F.
Cart. Cart in Ohio?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- That's what I was thinking,
but you said F I was like, what?
- Yeah. And again, this is
what I'm proud of Tyler.
You know what kind of great
moment this is for me?
You're deeply respected
and educated in the game
and you bring up something
and I can name the set,
like I'm doing my work.
- Yeah. And I appreciate that.
- I knew that.
I knew that.
Like if I was really doing this,
just so everybody knows what
that's going to look like,
the bad version of me,
here's what it's going to look like.
They're going to pick a high
production current thing
that is low cost,
buy them like crazy.
And then, so you would
pump the 13th pick...
What pick was Giannis? 13?
- 14.
- 14 I think.
- If you're gonna do that move,
you're going to take the 14th.
There was a weird draft.
There was no much madness.
It's super weird.
So one can claim that, here's
what they're going to do.
They're going to claim
that this is a weird draft
and they didn't do the same kind of work.
And that you love the
14th player in the draft.
They're going to load up on
14th player for fucking months.
The production of fucking prison next year
is gonna be through the, just
gonna be a billion (fumbles)
- Yeah.
- And they should have
banned the business model
I don't come at them.
- Yeah I do not blame
them if they keep selling.
- And they're going to load up
and that's what they're
going to pump with no data,
with no on the court,
not fucking hey, I think rare
things that look like antiques
and art that there's
only 39 of have a shot.
Not LeBron. I got shit on
for LeBron James rookie.
(all laugh)
Thank you. Please guys,
Can anybody look at what
Robert McQueen did last year?
How do you get shit on for that?
- Yeah.
- Like, does anybody ever
seen Devin Booker's numbers?
Plus I knew, which is why I've
been scoping the whole time,
what Devin Booker thinks
about fame and floss.
So I knew he was also
out and cared about that.
I knew the Kendall
thing was an inevitable.
I didn't know it was Ken or,
but that matters. Matters for fame.
So like I just that's for anybody
who's listening right now.
Like, listen, I understand everything.
But I do think the merit of a man's words
should be part of the equation.
And I find it very difficult.
If you look here for Jordan stickers,
like Hakeem Olajuwon,
like look at every piece
of content I put out.
Luca. Like, I, I like, I dunno man.
I don't know. Like my Kaboom
theory, like what I just said,
I think it's logical.
Like when you bring up some obscure thing
I know it's cons, like, I'm on my shit.
You know, I know that basketball vintage
goes through the roof.
You gotta look at football
vintage because what's going on?
This doesn't make sense.
You know?
Like I don't know man.
But I do know this Tyler and Jak and Nate,
I got shit on in the liquor business
when I first got into it,
this Internet's a fad.
He's just a kid.
Sasha you shouldn't let
your kid do these things.
You're going to go out of business.
And then I became yes.
I know that when I started
doing social media,
everyone's like you've lost your mind,
the fuck is this?
My space is stupid.
It's for kids, dah, dah, dah,
and then I become a genius.
By the way listen, quote unquote,
I don't think I'm a genius.
Then I started advertising agency.
Everybody shits on me.
What does the wine guy know about that?
Then fucking Vayner happens right?
Let me tell you what
was happening in my life
when I was getting shit on by everybody
in the card industry.
Everybody was shitting on me
in the real life business world.
Have I lost my mind? Cards are stupid.
Like ultimately,
the reason I'm able to be empathetic
and can understand opinions
is I know my opinion of myself
and your opinion of me
actually don't matter.
What matters is what ends
up happening to be true.
- Yeah.
- Yup.
Wow. I can't believe we
actually did this to be honest.
- We appreciate a lot.
- When Tyler said he got
you I was like, really?
We're doing this?
- I hope everybody's having fun.
If you enjoy this interview,
hit me up on Twitter and Instagram.
I can't wait to meet
every single one of you
on card shows around the
country once we can do it.
I'd love to engage all of you.
And, and I really appreciate
the opportunity gang
and we'll talk soon.
- Yep.
- Oh yeah.
Appreciate it.
- It's been a pleasure.
Thank you so much.
- Thank you guys. Take care, bye bye.
Hey everybody on YouTube.
First of all, thank you so much.
So humbled for your time.
I don't wear a watch, but
time is the biggest asset.
So thank you for watching that video.
If you got some value out of that,
there's plenty more where that came from.
Feel free to check it out.